Hey,
what's going on?
It's bill burr and a,
as promised I told you I was going to give you an extra 15 minutes and I know
there's a bunch of your wine and on Twitter.
Oh my God.
You said you're going to put it up Wednesday and now it's Thursday.
That isn't what you said.
Watch your fucking grow up.
All right,
was cool hand Luke once said,
well,
you people stop [inaudible] these fucking eggs.
He said something like that.
Nah,
I'm just kidding.
Look,
I had a busy fucking day.
You know,
what do you want from me?
I had such a crazy week.
Um,
I was actually at an acting gig yesterday and I thought,
you know,
I looked and I was like,
this is three,
four pages,
you know,
all this shit's gonna be over in a couple of hours.
And,
um,
it ended up,
I ended up being there like 12 hours from like eight to eight.
It was basically it,
Eh,
uh,
daddy drinks at night.
So that's why you didn't get your podcasts.
Oh,
Jesus.
Um,
I had a fucking brutal day.
I just had one of these days where nothing worked out and I didn't flip up until
the end of the day.
I'm really working on my temper.
I first thing I did was I,
I had to do a something this morning,
uh,
looping,
it's called looping.
It's basically when you shoot something and then,
yeah,
somebody made a noise or you sat down some books or somebody scratched their
fucking balls and that sound of fingers and pubes basically they want to get
your line clean so you have to go over to this recording place and then they
show you the line that you said,
and then they count it down,
boop,
boop.
And then you fucking jumped in and you got to say the line you just said.
So I had to do that this morning at 9:00 AM right.
So I punched in the fucking directions,
right.
I moved the Prius and I get out my fucking truck,
take that up to top of the driveway and I'm off.
Right.
And I put in the gps shit and
uh,
I actually gps to whatever the fuck you call it,
did it on the iPhone.
Okay.
What I did was I put in the address of the person who sent me the email telling
me where I was supposed to go.
My dumb ass drove to my agent's office and I'm like,
wow,
this is like really close to my agent's office.
And I was like,
wait,
this is my agent's office.
And I was a half hour fucking late and that's how it started and I didn't lose
my shit.
Yeah.
Nope.
I just gave it out.
I just,
I somehow got through it and I finally snapped when I got home after a bunch of
Shit went wrong,
I went to get fucking light bulbs at home depot and I put the one the size that
I needed.
I took it out and I put in my pocket because those new squiggly ones,
you know,
the old school ones that were just an old light bulb,
it said 75 watts or whatever.
I can't figure out where the fuck they are.
Long Story Short,
I get out of the car,
I turn around,
I bang into my truck and I smashed the light bulb in my pocket,
still have not snapped,
still haven't snapped.
I can't even remember half the shit cause I don't even care.
By the time I got home,
I go to get my fucking car,
the Prius to go pick up Nia.
And uh,
I get there in the fucking battery's dead cause I left it on like a boombox or
some shit.
And um,
but it turned on just enough for me to put the key in and when it's still on,
it wouldn't shut off and I couldn't get my key out.
So that's when I fucking snapped.
And I believe I slapped the dashboard like maybe anywhere between five and 36
times.
I can't remember.
And then I fucking just tried to Yank my keys out and I broke the plastic thing
on it.
So there you go.
That was my day.
Was that even remotely interesting?
Ah,
Jesus,
I don't give a fuck.
What do you want from me?
I had a brutal day,
so I snapped one time.
Um,
but anyways,
and I only think of where you worked all day yesterday at 12 hour day.
By the time you did you lazy artists,
did you get a chance to watch the Bruins game?
I came on,
I was on,
you know,
we're down where we were working and I,
I kept checking.
Um,
I try not to be that asshole who in between takes is fucking looking at his
Twitter and stuff.
I try not to be that guy,
but uh,
you know,
come on,
it's a playoff game.
This is a huge game and I'm not here to talk any shit.
Everybody.
I got to tell you,
I am just as stunned as penguin fence.
You know,
I said at the beginning of this series,
I said,
my brain said penguins and six,
my heart says Bruins and seven,
I am fucking dumbfounded with how great we're playing and how,
uh,
how we're doing it against what I thought was the best team in the NHL.
Certainly the team with the most talent and um,
you know,
I dunno.
So I actually just watched the re I came home and it was in the middle of the
second overtime and I ran into the bathroom real quick when I came out,
uh,
Bergie had scored and I was fucking psych,
but I wasn't psyched the way I would've been a five and watching it from the
beginning,
uh,
I was more relieved because,
um,
you know,
Campbell went down and I remember that time we went up three games to none.
And Craig,
you went down and then that other can't came back for the flyers and all of a
sudden the whole momentum switched.
So look,
I lived through the dark years of being a Boston sports fan.
So it's,
it ain't over till it's over.
We're up three games to none.
Anything can fucking happen.
Uh,
I'm hoping we close them out cause I don't want to give these guys any bit of
life because you know,
there's a lot of guys in that team that have the name on the Stanley Cup,
so on.
I don't what to tell you.
I'm fucking thrilled.
And for all you people out there who will giving me Shit,
you know.
Okay.
About whatever I said about your boy.
They're on your team.
Listen,
that shit.
Marshawn debord he stuck out his knee on a Chris Coolers.
Kesha now got two minutes for slashing them back.
He should have been allowed to smash his stick over his fucking head.
Anytime anybody sticks then the out like that's a piece of shit.
Fucking move.
See that penguin,
feds.
Now why don't you try doing that with your boy there.
All right,
we start guys only five feet tall.
We got a little Tasmanian Devil and I like to have what's his face?
Bread didn't um,
Mauro,
whatever the fuck his name is,
get their Marshawn's face.
I like that.
I like seeing that I,
that doesn't make me mad.
I'll make me hate the other team.
I like seeing people with fucking hot add a penguins game to play and that that
third game they just fucking couldn't score a goal.
What about Johnny boy chuck
and the fucking second overtime?
Yeah.
Two saves that,
that first one he had on Crosby was going in the fucking net.
Um,
I dunno,
you guys heard how I talked about the Bruins all year.
I didn't have any faith of them.
I'm like,
they can't score more than two goals.
I'm actually blown away.
They just flipped the switch.
But a,
I'll tell you scaring the shit out of me the most is the La kings because
nobody's talking about them and they just won the fucking cup.
They kind of being disrespected and there are big ass fucking team and that game
is 18 minutes old at this point.
When I'm doing it and I'm calling it right fucking now,
kings are winning the game and they went in the series at my heart.
Won't let,
let,
let me say that they're going to win the cup.
They're going to play the Bruins.
Hopefully in the Stanley Cup finals and a,
we will have our work cut out for ourselves.
All right,
so there you go.
There's my hockey talk for the week.
Now let's get to talking about religion.
Oh,
oh
Yay.
Um,
I got an email.
Actually,
it wasn't said to me,
it was sent to somebody else.
I know.
And then they would just like,
hey,
you might want to check this out.
So I thought it was going to be one of those emails where they were like,
you know,
hey bill,
how are ya?
Just want to tell you I saw you on a slap these fucking Ying-yang show.
And I really thought you were funny,
but it wasn't like that at all.
Uh,
this is guy is a Catholic and he has a fucking bone to pick with make.
All right,
so strap yourselves in for this one.
Starts off.
It says,
this message is for bill crybaby fucking Burr and I hope to Christ he gets it
because I'm too worked up to search for a way to get this to him directly.
What's again not mad at this guy I'm loving is pash.
He's right.
My grill right now,
he's on the bench and I'm standing there after I fucking gave him a knee to
knee.
I actually,
I went knee to knee on all they'll fucking bearded baby there evidently.
So here he goes.
He continues.
Let me tell you something.
Birth.
I'm trying to give this a good read.
I'm pointing as I do this.
You sly me.
Fuck
you.
Don't just,
just like the Catholics.
You fucking hate them.
I don't know what happened to you and your life to make you hate the Catholics.
Maybe you were molested.
Well,
yeah.
Maybe if I was raped by a priest.
Don't you think that that would be a logical fucking reason?
Would that still make me a crybaby?
All
right.
There we go.
We're just getting going.
Maybe you were molested.
Maybe he had to attend too many midnight masses on Christmas Eve.
Nah,
that's copping out.
Pussies did that.
You get up on Christmas Day,
you do your paper routes,
then you go,
you take a shower and then you go to the mass.
Then you have a big breakfast and then you open your gifts.
That's how it was done in my house.
Are you guys getting it out of the way?
Hey Jesus.
Hey,
quick,
high five.
Just want to say what's up before I go to bed.
All right,
Bang my fucking wife and uh,
just on some presence.
Thanks for everything you've done for me.
Um,
anyways,
he says,
or maybe your mommy and daddy forced you to go to church against your will.
Uh,
well,
yeah,
of course they did.
As did yours.
What were you doing when you were five?
You know,
I'm really enjoying climbing this tree board I really,
really would love to do is to put on some uncomfortable clothes and listen to
some adults go horror movie for a fucking hour.
They didn't force me to do it.
It's not like I had any rights,
you know,
they weren't my parents.
They can do whatever they want it to,
as did George Surf.
So anyways,
he goes and you're still resentful of it,
like rebelling,
rebelling little teenage bitch.
I don't fucking know,
but I'm tired of hearing about it.
We get it.
Hey,
hey,
speak for yourself,
sir.
Don't use,
we say that you're sick of it.
Say I'm sick of it.
Be a big boy now.
Um,
he says the fact is the,
they hold I,
the fact is that you can't talk about whatever the fuck the fact is.
You can talk about whatever the fuck you want to talk about.
That's your right.
Well,
thank you.
Thank you.
Thank you very much for backing up the constitution.
He says,
but there's a lot of us where I come from who are tired of your,
I'm a poor,
recovering Catholic.
Whiny crybaby fucking story.
You whiny little bitch.
I got it sir.
I got it.
You're calling me whiny.
Um,
how can you wine is,
is it really considered wining where you're like,
I'm done with an organization that sided with the pedophiles,
you know,
quit your whining.
Um,
he said,
I happened to like your comedy a lot.
Very nice.
Draw me back in.
It's salt me for nine paragraphs,
then pull me back in.
Go for the ego.
Very smart move.
I liked this guy.
He said,
but I'm sick and tired of you attacking my faith.
Will do.
That's why there's other podcasts.
Okay.
There's all kinds of part.
I bet you can find one.
Um,
I don't know.
Jesus is awesome podcast.
Why don't you go listen to Stryper?
They have like a bug 19 album's about that.
You know,
you can put on some fucking yellow and black striped pajamas,
you know,
change your last name to sweet teas up your fucking hair.
You could have a great time.
Why you acting like I'm the only fucking podcast out there and you're being
subjected to this.
You're not.
There's a whole big beautiful free world for you out there,
sir.
Download what you want.
Is that anyways,
he continues.
He goes,
the thing that kills me,
I like to see is bringing it down.
He's crossing his legs now.
He's going Colombel one.
The thing that kills me is that you try to be so open minded and fair about a
lot of things and I respect that.
But how about being fair with the Catholics?
Uh,
sir,
I'm not yelling at Catholics.
I'm yelling at the Catholic Church.
That's what I'm mad at.
Those people who's murdered,
tortured and raped people,
those ones who always seemed to be on the wrong side and a World War II,
right?
Jewish people are trying to fucking follow where the hell all this shit went and
where,
where does part of it lead to?
Huh?
Who had some of this shit fallen out of their pockets?
The Catholic church,
right.
They would play at both sides of the shit on one side right there.
High five and Fdr it fucking uh,
Walt Frazier there.
What the fuck's his name?
We shall never surrender Winston Churchill.
Right?
And on the other side they're going,
hey,
we go wade off.
There we go.
This scumbag.
So I'm not attacking you.
You're taking this as an attack.
I'm not.
All right.
Are you really going to sit there and tell me that you enjoy that music bad at
Bain and I bought,
I bought a bowl by a paypal
whap out of that [inaudible] why did I babble?
Xibalba booboo.
Yeah.
Dot.
I booboo.
I mean,
how many times can you fucking go there and you can go as many times when I'm
not giving you shit,
sir.
You're really taking this personally.
So any guys,
no,
no doubt.
What happened was fucking wrong and you aren't the only one who's second bite.
Okay.
We agree.
It's something he goes,
trust me.
He goes,
I have plenty to tell you about being a catholic growing up,
but you don't see me fucking whining about it.
I don't know why you think of wine.
I think I'm telling jokes and people are laughing and I don't think you'd like
the jokes and I,
you're trying to say it's that I'm whining.
I'm not here going,
okay,
well I try within Catholic,
I'm not doing that.
I'm just
go wipe out Beta.
Bada Bada boom,
Bada Bang table.
I'm scat singing,
which I claimed that I hate.
She can call me hypocrite.
So when he goes,
he goes,
I wasn't molested,
but I had some friends who were,
well,
oh my God,
right there.
I swear to God.
Okay,
if I didn't give a shit about my house,
I would have taken this microphone in this mixer and just throw it through my
fucking window.
Well,
let me ask you this,
sir.
Okay?
You had friends that were molested
yet you still go to the church,
okay.
Now,
if you walked into a pet store,
let's pick a chain.
All right?
If you walked into Wendy's,
okay.
At two of your buddies got molested in there,
would you go back to Wendy's?
Would you really sit there and be like,
look,
it's not the Burgers,
it's the,
it's the fucking guy on the fries burgers.
Fine.
Now what if the people making the burgers were covering for the guy on the fries
and they put them over there on the fly of fish.
Put a couple more of them over there on the apple pies.
Huh?
I just jumped fucking fast food chains,
whatever.
I'm not familiar with the Wendy's menu.
I find that more.
May I find you'll fucking anger at me at me who never touched your friends?
Never fucking uh,
I dunno.
Had An inquisition.
I don't got any Nazi money.
You know,
I don't tell you that you're born into sin.
The second year board.
I mean that just that fucking thing.
And if you don't get,
if you don't get dunked in this water that we dashed that fucking shit in that
this baby,
you're going to burn in hell forever because some check ate an apple ad fucking
when asked a mouth like a weak law,
whatever the fuck's the story is right.
Whatever you want to be mad at me.
Be Mad at me,
sir.
I'm sure you can kick the shit out of me,
but I think you have misdirected anger.
You know?
Let me ask you this.
Were you upset when they took away all those wins at Penn State?
Were you upset by that?
Actually I was.
I thought that was bullshit because the players didn't do it.
That's a bad example.
I don't fucking know.
I don't know.
I was a little bit,
were you upset when they took down?
What's his face?
His statue there?
Huh?
What's the matter?
Oh look who's here.
Look who just decided to wander red here.
I got it.
I got a mic here for you.
The lovely Nia.
Everybody.
Okay?
Who's that?
This guy is just going off on me.
Nia,
are you there?
Can you wait?
Wait,
wait my level,
how your levels are.
My Miko gilts are me up to the baseline now.
How come that isn't working?
I don't know.
Are you sure?
I can see me when I'm talking.
Wait,
but I'm way louder cause you always louder.
There we go.
Not now talk.
Hello?
Hello.
There you go.
I'm hearing an echo.
I don't know why,
but I like it.
Um,
so this guy's going off of me because I've been,
because you took an idea like cold lotion and ran with it.
And then the knowledge,
that collaborative effort that went into the cold lotion.
What was the collaborative effort?
I put it on your back.
Yes.
And you went,
you freaked out and said,
oh it's cold.
And you're like,
is there anything worse than if someone puts cold lotion on you?
And I laughed.
He said,
that sounds like a seventies term.
And I said,
that's some cold lotion.
And you were like,
I said that.
No,
I said,
that's an old of my God.
You said it sounded like those sort of 70th lag black guy,
jive,
whatever saying that I said it.
And I said,
that's some cold lotion.
Oh my God.
No.
I said,
are you really,
you have the nerve to make these people.
Maybe you came up with it.
I swear to God,
how dare you.
But you,
but you were the why did ever,
why do I not go?
I Dunno.
You're the one that said it is a seventies type of thing,
which it really does sound like and then that's what then I said it.
I go man,
that's up coal lotion.
That's why I said no.
I said that's some cold lotion.
Well that's a big difference that you just said.
I did say now you said,
I feel like I said it.
Look,
if you want to split this drift,
I don't,
I didn't want to make this ugly here.
You know.
I'll give you full credit.
Hi.
But I play right now full credit check and credit for cold lotion is cold
lotion.
Oh wait,
you left me out of it with some cold loans.
You called lotion me uncle.
No,
this is what it is.
What it is.
I have you on my podcast is a guest and you come on like you're going to be all
cool and then you start attacking me.
That's cold motion.
All right?
You call lotion neighbors.
Oh,
whatever.
Whatever.
Sick.
Let me,
let me,
let me continue with this hashtag called lotion.
Alright,
let's make cold cold lotion happen.
No,
no,
no.
They,
they decide.
Don't fucking beg for it.
Needy.
I'm not begging you.
Sounded a little desperate state.
Oh,
shut up.
All right.
What's this guy talking about?
But he's trashing me.
He's trashing me because I,
I make come.
He says,
I,
I trash Catholics.
I whine about it.
He says,
I keep whining about it.
And he said wine like 50 times.
And I think I'm in the fourth paragraph.
So,
uh,
so you actually,
you got to be said that he agreed with being,
obviously the molestation was bad.
He goes,
I was never molested,
uh,
when I was a kid,
but I had some friends who were,
it goes together.
We went through a lot,
but I knew then at 12 years old,
this isn't what the real church is about.
I,
I'm 100% in agreement with that,
but I think you need to go beyond,
hey,
the real churches about fucking my friends against their will.
I also don't think it's about like you're born into sin and all that and I'm
allowed to have that opinion,
but I'm not coming at you anyways.
So he goes to true still remains.
Even if a bunch of fucking dead beat human beings and pedophiles jumped in there
and fucked it all up.
You know what?
You know what that's called?
It's called evil.
And why wouldn't evil go after the church?
The basis of the church is still there.
And instead of attack and get,
maybe you should at least find your way through the layers of shit,
which I admit have existed in the past and they pass and take a closer look.
Douchebag.
But wait a minute,
wait a minute.
So my question to this guy is,
okay,
you're making it sound like there's little pockets of evil.
I want you to explain to me the inquisition.
I want you to explain to me them having the spoils of Nazi pilfering in their
pockets.
I want you tell me why they made this decision to hide these pedophiles and I
mean the organization from top to bottom is dirtier than fucking professional
cycling.
All right,
so you're making it seem like this,
this like,
hey,
there's a,
there's always going to be a couple of bad apples in the barrel.
It's like the whole pyramid is fucked up the whole way that they got everybody
on board I believe is fucked up.
All right.
You shouldn't have to murder and torture people to believe in to get them to
believe in your version of the shit.
And I don't know how as an adult you could look at your religion and then see
other adults with a completely different religion and then just feel without a
doubt
yours is right.
100% right.
I'm looking at this letter though,
just on your computer and it's like there is a very,
not even vaguely,
there's like a seriously threatening tone to it.
Not In a,
in a serious way,
but he goes,
if you ever,
and I mean ever,
every capital letters wants to talk more about this.
Why?
Like,
it sounds like he's a really upset and I promise I can be civil about it.
You fucking call me and we'll discuss it.
He's like me.
I don't think he's that led to me.
It sounds,
it sounds to me like you need some answers and I'm the fucking guy to give him
to you.
He does sound like you.
You are screwed up on some shit when it comes to the Catholics.
Don't be fucking pussy,
I guess up.
Was He talk with somebody or don't?
I don't give a shit four exclamation points that I don't have shit.
I,
Oh,
you're right.
I don't have shit that was so worked up over this.
He forgot to put it in a couple of words.
You obviously give a shit.
You wrote.
I have a football game this weekend and I've got to pretend the guy across from
me is use.
This guy's at that Lyman,
so I'll give him a pass on not having give cause he plays those big fat sausage
fingers.
Oh man,
we could make 1 million bucks doing that.
Why don't we make a big fat sausage finger for people with big fat sausage
finger keyboards.
Oh,
that's awesome.
Sausage finger and all you
have to do it.
Just have,
you know,
some little guy,
nerdy guy typing away,
having a good time.
Right.
And then you have the other guy wanting to look at porn on the Internet,
but he can't because he has,
isn't it like that restaurant where we uh,
hear about that on TV?
Is it in Vegas or something where if you're over 250 pounds,
you eat for free and people were like to,
to borrow from you.
I've run my hands a whole people are really upset about it because they feel
like they're like rewarding obesity because they have something called like,
you know,
they have like one of those burgers that has four patties in eight slices,
the cheese and I'm literally selves to death.
Your overall,
if you're,
if you're to fifth year over,
you can eat in this restaurant for free.
I don't get that.
So how do you got to eat more and you're going to lose money?
It's just the,
I think it's just a stupid gimmick.
Um
Oh wait a minute.
Yeah,
but you fucking flipped my switch.
This title,
people over 50 have a lot of smaller friends that'll come with them.
Maybe?
No,
but they're the only ones that do,
they have to drive him over in the van.
You know those people,
they have like that.
They just got to roll them into like one of those old Ford Astros and then you
drive while we're here in module eight,
maybe they're so fat they have to have people bring the food out to them and
then those people.
Yeah,
you give me a number seven.
I think he told the Dude's a whole thing was like,
he recognizes that there are a lot of big people in this world and I don't know,
I think he was trying to spin it into some like positive thing.
Oh well hey,
here's one.
I went over to the home depot today and only wanting to do some light bulbs and
I needed this hacksaw to cut up something metal.
You know,
it's stupid curtain rod that we have sticking up against our fence.
Like we're fucking Sanford and son.
I want to cut that thing up.
You have so no,
but that's for wood.
Oh,
okay.
So it's for the,
I use it once a year for the Christmas tree.
Um,
and you like doing it too?
I liked,
I liked disposing it properly.
People really do just throw their Christmas trees out on the curb,
like center.
That's bad enough.
The holidays over
mugging victim,
just laying there fight always looks like a dead body to me.
I always feel like,
you know,
like
I always hear like fucking,
uh,
that truck's lab as far as I can remember.
I always wanted to be a gangster.
I tweeted something because
I was driving behind somebody who put their,
um,
their Christmas tree and the trunk,
but it was sticking out,
you know,
all the leaves or branches or whatever.
They King Sos and I said they got this,
um,
Christmas tree in here looking like Billy batts.
Good.
Very nice.
See,
nobody said you didn't have a good references.
They need,
um,
hashtag coastal lotion.
So,
um,
yes,
but how was it also going to help?
I bought a hall going to Home Depot.
He said new scam,
at least the home depot around the corner.
All right.
And I'm just talking about home depot,
sir.
I'm not trashing the cat and I really hope I'm not whining.
I go in there,
so I'm just getting a couple of products.
I didn't want him to be a giant,
I don't want to be a giant,
whatever you call those things that you're pushing around with the four wheels
clapping,
shopping carts.
Yeah.
Oh,
I go,
do you have one of those little little baskets I could skip around the store
with,
throw some pedals around,
and then they're like,
and they're like,
no,
we don't have,
we don't have them,
but we do have these.
And there was these home depot buckets,
like the kind of stuff you die of a bunch of shit in,
you know,
like,
like a blank,
like a bucket.
Yeah.
So I'm like,
well,
I don't want that thing.
And they go,
yeah,
we understand that.
So I start walking around the store,
filling up the bucket.
I'm troll alone,
you know,
getting the sign,
all this stuff's scheme and they gave you the basket.
So they know they have a whole stack of them.
They don't,
they don't have baskets,
they just have buckets,
buckets.
Now Home Depot on the bucket,
I assume it's a home depot bucket me up.
I don't know how else to explain it.
Okay.
So I'm filling up to stuff and then I get up to the register and the guy starts
running it up and it just seemed a little high.
And I,
you know,
after he's done ringing and goes,
48,
23 and I went,
hey,
you know,
I don't want the bucket.
They charge in any goes.
And he goes,
oh,
okay,
okay.
And I was just like,
yeah,
take it off.
And he goes,
all right to get it taken off.
You've got to go stand in this line over here.
Oh,
but,
but he,
but I was just like,
oh,
I started laughing.
I was like,
ah,
those bastards.
And he got all like,
like,
where do I go?
No Sir.
And I'm going to do,
and I'm not saying you,
I'm not saying,
yeah,
I go,
you know the game up to,
I couldn't get them to crack.
He,
he was,
he was fucking like the Home Depot Manchurian candidate.
He's like,
sorry sir,
but what will go?
So that's the new shit.
So now they take the fucking bucket back.
Now he got all his shit.
How do I carry so they don't have the little plastic bags,
Les Brown plastic bag and see home depot on them.
They don't give them to you anymore.
No,
they don't have bucket or nothing.
They don't have the little basket Trella lies.
They don't have the trial allows anymore.
Now you either have to use a shopping cart or bucket.
Yeah.
So then they took the bucket away.
They said,
well,
okay,
we'll take the bucket away.
And I go,
now what I did,
they go,
you got to carry this stuff out.
And I was like,
you know what,
I will,
that's some cold low now.
Right.
We're killing it now.
No.
Um,
I kia does that.
Ikea,
if you want a bag,
you get an ikea bag.
And I don't know how much it's like 35 cents but something but just cheap enough
so it doesn't,
it might break you,
but just annoying enough to say why should I have to pay for a bag?
No,
cause they're brilliant because what they cause all those plastic bags or going
out into the ocean and the choking out the porpoises,
right.
So all the,
all the hippies who are like,
hey man,
like you guys get to start with the plastic bags,
man.
So they're like,
fine.
So now there's like a charge.
If you want to get a plastic bag,
but they're a corporation,
they're going to try to make money.
They're trying to hide behind this with some environmental.
That's bullshit because there's plenty of places where you can still get a
plastic bag.
You can get it at the Walgreens and get the damn grocery store.
So they don't,
they don't care about the porpoises.
I know they don't,
they care about making money,
but I like even when the hippies try to get them,
they still figure out a way.
Hippies like we really are still in the sixties and seventies there's no more
hippies.
Why can't you let me off my fun?
Oh,
but you're just,
you're just as much of a Hippie as anybody else.
You're running around unplugging,
plugging things.
I wish I had hair like a hippie.
Shrieking.
I look like a principal.
You're very concerned about the environment.
Are you a hippy?
Uh,
I'm not going to.
I try not to.
I try not to be a voice for so annoying about that.
You are a hippie.
You're just as bad as the people you're talking.
You're not fucking plug.
I'm not showered with mint tea or whatever the fuck it is.
They do.
Don't they all smell like put your spices?
MMM.
No,
I'm not a hippie.
Just because you give a shit.
Well,
these people give a shit too.
So why are they happy is because I was just trying to be funny.
Oh,
okay.
Is that all right?
All right.
We were only supposed to do 15 minutes,
so this is an extra 15 for all the people on the Internet.
Where is it,
man?
Oh,
hey.
You know what?
I got a big announcement to make.
I'm preggers no,
whoever says I have a big announcement,
they always has to be on pregnant.
Um,
where is it here
please tweet that,
that bill burrs pregnant,
do a mock up of bill burr pregnant first trimester.
And I have to look as excited as a first time mom.
Um,
so wait,
wait,
wait.
Here we go.
Ah,
I have a tour.
If,
you know,
this is the thing,
the people always come up to me after my shows and they'll say,
hey,
we,
we drove four hours to the shelf.
Don't you tear it,
don't you turn my fucking well,
I want to read it.
Okay.
So they'll come up to me at the end of my shows.
They'll be like,
we drove four hours,
you know,
six hours,
eight hours.
I've had people like,
we flew in here from Blah,
blah,
blah.
And I was like,
you know,
that means something,
right?
So I was like,
I called up my agent and go,
well,
why don't I go out to some of these more obscure places?
MMM.
You know where these people are at.
So I came up with this tour
or my agent did.
It's going to be basically all the middle of the country.
It's the,
uh,
it's the Billy red state tour.
Billy red state going to have t shirts and fucking everything.
I start off on July 26th at the Morris Morrison Center in Boise,
Idaho.
All right.
Then July 27th,
my first time ever in this state,
and obviously performing there at the Emerson theater in Bozeman,
Montana.
All right.
Then I go to a what?
July 28th.
I'm at the deadwood mountain grand events center in Deadwood,
South Dakota.
Wow,
that's cool.
I too,
I'm getting another bus meeting.
I'm going to gain 10 pounds a whiskey baby.
July 29th,
uh,
the boulder theater in Boulder,
Colorado.
July 30th pikes peak center in Colorado Springs,
Then I'm at the Orpheum theater July 31st in Wichita,
Kansas.
Then August 1st.
So I'm doing the Tom Brady theater.
It's just the Brady theater.
I hope that's not,
uh,
like Brady Bill Brady.
Then it's really disrespectful.
My fault.
Brady theater in Tulsa,
Oklahoma.
Then,
uh,
I got a private event and the second on the third,
um,
at the Abraham Chavez theater in El Paso,
Texas,
the official Billy red state tour,
a cavalcade of dates in the middle of nowhere from July 26 to August 3rd,
uh,
tickets are already on sale for a or should be on sale for Boise,
Bozeman,
deadwood,
boulder,
Colorado Springs,
and Tulsa,
Oklahoma.
At least I have links.
I'm going to get those up on the pop up on the website as soon as I can.
And uh,
I never watched the show,
but was that is dead?
I never watched the actual did it take place there?
I have no idea if that's just a bad ass name.
That's just a bad,
bad ass name though.
My commodity.
Some good looking cowboy tried to talk game do you came up right?
You weren't with me,
right?
You're already liking this comes walking.
Can it wait,
where are you automatically?
So yeah,
I'm with you.
Yeah.
Where are you from?
From
where you from?
Cowboy deadwood,
South Dakota.
That's a bad accent.
That wasn't sexy at all.
Wasn't no.
Who are you thinking of?
You thinking of a fucking Michael Moore there and uh,
Michael Moore.
Tell me Fellman Luis Grad fit what?
I think Michael Moore did.
He play somebody named Michael.
Um,
all right,
that's the podcast for this week.
I want to go watch the,
uh,
the kings and Black Hawks.
And like I said,
I feel like the kings not only gonna win game two,
I think they're going to win the series if they play their game.
That's a big ass fucking team.
Ah,
Jesus.
Paul Versey who's going to be on the Billy [inaudible] Billy red state tour as
is,
uh,
Jason Law had Jason Lawhead all the bands getting back together.
Hey,
first he let me call you right back.
I'm finishing a podcast.
All right.
That's it.
And uh,
play eight,
by the way,
Nhl hockey finally getting its due on the cover of sports illustrated.
It says something like the best game or the best whatever and it just has like
on the covers back east is going to be the Bruins I think against the rangers.
Cause I think,
uh,
you know,
they got to go to press I think,
I don't think it's against,
might be against the penguins.
And then they have the,
uh,
maybe they just have the conference finals,
but they're talking about how the NHL playoffs or the greatest like,
you know,
I love it.
This,
this far like this deep into the playoffs,
they,
any player they interview has like stitches on their face or a fat lip.
What about that guy?
We saw that guy in the black box.
If that guy,
the kinks,
he literally looked like,
I like,
he stuck his face in a woodchipper.
How like how excited you are during hockey season.
I,
I fucked.
It's all coming together now.
You are,
you're always so happy during hockey season.
You're like a little school boy on Christmas Day.
Every day you're liking low.
Oh boy.
Go Watch the game.
Texting me in the middle of the day.
Nini,
can you take this such and such game for me?
I love it.
Yeah.
I'm actually bummed that it's so,
I love that it's getting the respect,
but I liked it.
It's underground.
It's like a band that you love and you can get good fucking sit close and watch
them before all the fucking scream in horror show up.
And then next thing you know,
you're up in the upper deck.
Go.
You know what I mean?
I watched him in the fucking,
um,
I followed this guy,
uh,
on,
on Twitter that has like,
puts up all these classic pictures and uh,
uh,
the guy who helps me with the podcast,
Andrew sent me this,
this unbelievable photo of,
I believe it's a rangers,
Montreal Canadiens game and he can see the crowd and this unbelievable color.
And uh,
it's just,
first of all,
you should see the crowd.
It's mostly guys.
Yeah.
And everybody is just dressed to the nines.
Oh,
for a hockey game,
dude suits overcoats the whole thing.
And you just think now the fat fucks with their faces.
Painted kids,
give him the finger and shit.
You know,
these whores running around with at t shirts tied off shooting tee shirts that
people catching them,
they can't even fit in.
The fucking thinks,
hey,
just wonder like,
what happened?
You know,
but I've never worn a suit and tie to a game,
so I'm part of the problem,
you know.
Do you know what would happen if you actually wore a suit and tie to a game?
Like people would look at you like what are you one of the owners?
Yeah.
Which is not a bad thing,
especially if you were sitting in one.
I like the fancy receipts.
Yeah.
But now,
you know,
back in the day I feel like people could hold their alcohol.
Uh Huh.
Feel like now you just going to show up and somebody is going to dump one of
those fucking 72 ounce,
big gulp.
Molsons all over a nice overcoat.
I Dunno.
Whatever.
I'll try to,
uh,
I'll try to give you guys a,
I'll try to post that somewhere and maybe next week if you guys remind me,
send me an email and I'll,
I'll,
I'll tell you who that guy is that I follow my Twitter.
Uh,
do I see Joe Rosa gave me great advice.
He took the Twitter APP office phone.
Oh yeah.
You told him.
I said that.
I did.
I took the Twitter app off and I took the Facebook f up because,
yeah.
Yeah,
because I was becoming one of these fucking zombies,
like every five seconds my phone would make an auto would,
which be checking,
checking,
checking.
Just what am I doing?
Facebook is the fucking worst because you know I love about Twitter.
It's smaller,
so if people really want to go on and on and they think cuts them off,
that's one of those quick answering machines,
right?
Facebook people can just go on and on.
Yeah.
How funny is it me saying that going on and on,
but like just some of this shit that like somebody wrote some stuff like,
you know,
I trusted somebody know and I guess that was wrong because you know,
I just,
I guess I care to,
it's whole fucking long thing.
I Dunno why I read it.
I'm just like,
why would you,
why would you put that out there?
Because you're trying to connect with people.
You're trying to share your feelings.
He gets,
you know,
also good that Colby Colby,
when he hurt his Achilles,
when as a kill,
he snapped.
He went out and he was just going,
what do I do?
Do I rehab it?
Do I just say to hell with it?
That's a great Coby and pricing Colby with no Achilles tendons paralyzed from
the fucking neck down could still kick my,
um,
all right,
there's 40 minutes.
All right.
There you go.
Just like that.
And another part or the best fucking thing that raccoon came in the back and
Cleo barked at it and then ran back to the door to look for you.
Look for me.
Let's go get that motherfucker.
And I was sitting right out there too,
and she saw,
she growled a little bit and he started barking and she did.
She ran back to the door and she was looking around like,
where are you?
Yeah,
let's get this
Si.
What a cat.
What a cat ever do.
Actually in order to cat would do,
a cat would just immediately take care of the problem and you'd have no idea.
And then it would just be sitting there with the dead body.
And you just be like,
glad to things on my side,
but it can be a little nervous.
Yeah.
Cleo really had this look on her face,
like,
where is he?
Does nothing like a big dark Dolores Daddy,
let's go.
All right,
cool.
All right.
That's the,
uh,
that's the bonus tracks for this week.
Thank you for being patient is always,
uh,
India and,
that is it.
Uh,
I'll talk to you guys later.
All right,
go bro.
Eds.